[Applaudissements]
alors moi j'ai étoffé l'émission l'année
dernière juste n'ai pas peur regarder
mon passage puisque j'ai pas canal+
je suis content de remonter sur scène
après le coronavirus je ne sais pas
compris toutes les règles qu'ils ont
expliqué ils ont dit qu'il fallait pas
s'approcher à moins d'un mètre de gens
que tu ne connais pas alors
personnellement je faisais déjà ça avant
il ya des gens qui ont mal vécu le
confinement je crois à bordeaux il ya
quelqu'un qui a pris un an de prison
ferme parce qu'il est sorti quatre fois
de chez lui et son argument c'était je
supporte mal d'être enfermé alors c'est
un endroit tu vas très mal supporté
d'être enfermé
bah ça en prison ou quoi j'ai fait les
tests du coc vide - l'a récemment j'ai
payé 70 euros l'infirmière m'a dit que
je l'avais pas je suis dit madame 70
euros
gelée
[Applaudissements]